tras más de una semana de violencia una
calma frágil reina en las calles de
belfast fue la muerte del príncipe
felipe la que convenció a algunos de los
manifestantes unionistas británicos a
posponer las protestas previstas para el
viernes por respeto a la familia real el
viernes la policía pidió a los líderes
comunitarios apaciguar las tensiones
peil de nuevo apeló a los que quieren
participar en este tipo de actividades
que no lo hagan no sirve de nada la
policía continuará investigando a los
que provocan desórdenes y cometen
delitos sobre materias falsos
durante los últimos días más de 70
policías han sido heridos durante las
protestas las peores en la región en
años
en el origen de las recientes tensiones
está la decisión de las autoridades
norirlandesas de no perseguir a líderes
del partido nacionalista sinn fein por
romper restricciones de la pandemia
los líderes asistieron a un funeral de
un importante miembro del ejército
republicano irlandés a pesar de la
prohibición de reuniones el incidente ha
vivo tensiones latentes entre unionistas
y nacionalistas que ya habían recibido
por el
no creo que los jóvenes realmente
entiendan los detalles de la frontera
marítima en la mesa creo que lo que les
dicen y lo que ven reflejado en los
medios es que el sinn fein está ganando
los republicanos están ganando y que
nuestra identidad está bajo ataque y
cuando escuchan esas palabras y cuando
les dicen de acuerdo pueden ayudar
saliendo a la calle y tirando bombas
palos y piedras a la gente están
dispuestos a hacerlo
como resultado del acuerdo del break
city irlanda del norte sigue siendo
parte del mercado único de la unión
europea por lo que se requieren
controles a los productos que llegan de
gran bretaña un cambio que algunos
unionistas creen que dañará la posición
de irlanda del norte en reino unido-